Fox News was trigly triggered into being
a sputtering Mess by Joe Biden's speech
last night saying hey we should try to
maintain our democracy
and Republicans running in November of
it running now in 2022 are increasingly
threatening to upend it if they lose if
I lose it was rigged if I won then it's
fair Joe Biden with a very good speech
which we already looked at take a look
at some of the reactions from
Republicans each I don't know whether
they call these sad whether they're
called these dangerous whether to to
call them delusional maybe it's a
combination let's look at them here's
Kevin McCarthy the House minority leader
reacting to Joe Biden's speech about
democracy being in danger that was the
announced subject matter we knew the
speech was going to be about democracy
and Kevin McCarthy says well it was a
bad speech because he didn't mention
inflation or gas prices I listened to
the president's speech I don't remember
hearing anything about inflation about
gas about border about fentanyl about
crime or not even the 98 individuals On
the Border who are on the terrorist
watch list they have caught what we're
really finding in these next six days
this is a hinge election this is this is
defining election like a 1980 election
which direction does America want to go
that's why we have the commitment to
America we literally spell out what
we'll do it's holding up a piece of
paper when he says that because energy
independent gives an economy that's
strong secure the Border fund the police
stop the prosecutors who are woke give
you a parent's Bill of Rights understand
that all of those things I mean the
economy at least for now is fine we have
almost full employment GDP growth is
back nothing has materially changed on
the border since Trump you know all
these things are completely made up but
the critique is he didn't talk about
inflation and gas prices the speech was
about democracy because Kevin McCarthy
and the cronies in his party and their
constituents seem not to care about
democracy anymore that's why the subject
matter was what it was
in reaction to Joe Biden's speech Jesse
Waters Another Beauty on Fox News
says this is all nonsense because we're
just gonna win there's not gonna be
anything to deny that was the president
of the United States confessing that
he's about to get wiped out a week from
now
no one is going to question the results
of this election Mr President because
it's going to be a blowout Now
understand
Jesse thinks he's being clever he thinks
he's being clever by saying you're not
going to have any questioning because
we're going to win there's not going to
be anything to question but he's
actually proving exactly the point that
Joe Biden made which is they don't
question it when they win and they
question it when they lose a priori
saying losses are fraud we'll talk later
about what a priori means uh he seems to
actually be proving Joe Biden's point
now is it true that Democrats are going
to get wiped out maybe we talked about
new polling at the same time there are
growing concerns that the new polling is
very bad polling we're going to find out
in you know what is it five days
we'll know before you know it just make
sure you take your vote and use it one
other clip here's Republican senator
Lindsey Graham also uh talking about Joe
Biden's speech and saying he didn't even
mention the Border well no it wasn't
about the Border Stacy Abrams herself
but that's not happening either uh what
was your reaction to Biden's angry
speech
by the way it's logical to be angry when
one side doesn't care about democracy uh
if I'm a liberal Democrat I would say
Joe please stop helping I thought it was
pathetic I thought it was divisive not
one word about how I'm going to secure a
broken border how I'm going to lower gas
prices as president how I'm going to
challenge rampant crime the money is he
already lowered gas prices as president
this energy independent it was if you
believe the president has anything to do
with it by the way which I don't but
again this is their story it's about
half the country uh basically being a
political terrorist yeah it's not half
the country that are political
terrorists but it's a non-zero portion
of the Republican party and we're seeing
it day to day these folks are pathetic
these folks are pathetic and they are
openly subscribing to
if we win it was fair
and if we lose it was rigged let me know
your thoughts in a comment or find me on
Twitter at dpacman remember we are
pushing to 2 million YouTube subscribers
many of you out there maybe I'm talking
about you you watch our clips on YouTube
but you're not subscribed do us the
favor of subscribing even if you're
seeing our videos in your feed because
it is the most important signal to
YouTube's algorithm hey maybe I should
recommend this guy's content
when you're looking for a good
documentary to watch you scroll through
Netflix and Hulu for a while there
aren't that many you realize you've seen
the good ones what if I told you there's
a streaming platform exclusively for
documentaries with the best selection
where you won't run out of top quality
documentaries that is curiosity stream
with a massive catalog of the newest and
best documentaries classic titles from
years ago exclusive content you can't
find anywhere else I just watched
Pompeii disaster Street I visited
Pompeii in Italy before I wish I had
seen the documentary before visiting
because it was made very clear I missed
a lot when I actually went to Pompeii
you can watch curiositystream on all of
your devices they're always adding new
titles politics philosophy True Crime
nature they have everything and my
audience gets curiosity stream for under
two bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below